[Musica]
ciao ragazzi benvenuti bentornati
svanite oggi nuova challenge super pazza
remo nascondino ma bendati anche io sono
bendata come sempre ci saranno quattro
round che perdo per più di due round
avrò perso la cia le vince chi trova
prima un'altra persona però da ben dal
prevedo che questa challenge sarà un po
un disastro
[Musica]
andate via non è ancora iniziata la
challenge
sicuramente non mi hanno sentito quando
sono andati via
ora mettetevi comodi prendete i pop corn
e lasciate un mi piace entro 5 secondi 5
4 3 2 1 o tempo scaduto se non mi
seguite ancora su instagram andate a
seguirmi nojani testori su secoli
sembrasse seguirmi anche su tik tok
siete pronti iniziamo subito la
challenge via torino si conta il gioco
rione squittino anche tu che ragazzi
primo round rametto la benda e vediamo
chi entrerà da quella porta
per ora non sento nessun rumore strano
pero di non sbattermi da nessuna parte
[Musica]
quasi un armadio
prova al tavolo magari mi nasconda sotto
al tavolo c'è il cuscino berlino si è
proprio il marito
rumore da quando è parte qua
[Musica]
abbiamo vinto il primo round
ho preso ice cream perché mi ha tirato
qualcosa addosso e ho capito dov'era
primo round detto ciao ragazzi secondo
round
c'è molto vento spero che vi sentiate
bene non so chi sia il prossimo nemico
il prossimo cattivo
iniziamo a vendersi e diamo via al
secondo round da che parte amiamo
eh no non è nessuno
sento il rumore
mariotto io ti amo
c'è qualcuno
benissimo fretta questo sì di un presto
vediamoci piccoli abbiamo vinto il
secondo round passiamo ora al terzo
round questo terzo round e all'aperto
vedete è ancora più pericoloso perché
potremmo sbattersi agli alberi o
inciampare e cadere nel fango
ancora non è comparso nessuno comunque
questa è la mia band diamo inizio al
terzo round è difficile sentire i passi
perché c'è il rumore del vento un albero
sento dei rumori ma non so chi è credi
devo scappare
non so dove sta andando il problema è
che creni è già ceca quindi riuscirà
comunque a trovarmi anche con la benda
sono quindi tel un cespuglio ore piene
da dietro
[Applauso]
[Musica]
quarto e ultimo round
apriamo la porta avvisiamo che ci
aspetta
pronti via si sente qualcuno che
tormenta sembra che provengano da questa
parte questi amori
berlino berlino berlino berlino
[Musica]
[Applauso]
bravissimo grazie a berlino abbiamo
vinto anche questa challenge ma se
volete la seconda parte con altri
personaggi sempre bendati anche se un po
complicato ma serve un bel video se su
questo video 30 mila mi piace uscirà
anche la seconda parte e ora vi lascio
qua 4 caselline scud ricardo vedere i
nostri altri video cliccate su quella
che preferite e buona visione
ciao